thank you
[Music]
all right this one's not about the
Heavies it's the husband yeah this one
was interesting there's a really really
strange crime that happened that had a
lot of uh conspiracy around it but so
far as far as hard evidence goes it's a
pretty normal thing which is sad to say
when you're talking about La so Nancy
Pelosi's residence right where does she
live Nor Cal she actually lives in
NorCal uh her husband was the only one
home right
a crazy homeless guy breaks into the
house like it just breaks the glass goes
in looking for Nancy wanting to take her
hostage and uh had some demands but
she's not there so then he confronts
Paul Pelosi the husband who is asleep at
the time this is around 2 30 a.m wow uh
confronts him he's got a hammer and uh
he's just kind of an unhinged crazy dude
so Paul Pelosi kind of doesn't really
know how to treat this but he ends up uh
asking if he can go to the restroom the
crazy guy lets him uh Paul Pelosi makes
a call to police and in code asks for
help he says something like oh I have
there's a person here who's like uh in
my home but then it doesn't set off the
dude because he's asking for help in
like a kind of a a weird way that makes
it sound like they're friends but the
cops understand the cops are like oh we
get it so they're sending someone over
they sent someone over there I'm home
that's a nice Hammer you got hanging
over there yeah he does something like
right at my head how sweet they ring the
doorbell someone opens the door they
don't know which one to open the door
apparently I don't know why that's a
[ __ ] undetermined thing uh doors open
they see Paul Pelosi struggling with
that guy the crazy guy they're
struggling with a hammer uh the hammer
guy ends up knocking out Paul Pelosi
cracks his skull whoa Paul's on the
ground they arrest the crazy guy the
crazy dude talks about how he wanted to
um he wanted to stop the misinformation
being spread by the Democratic party or
some [ __ ] and then after that a bunch of
new stuff started coming out excusing
them of like being lovers or some other
[ __ ] like a bunch of different
conspiracies that oh I believe that to
each other I believe that who and who
loved Paul Paul that this guy but this
dude has like the the hammer guy kind of
has a history of just being sort of like
a crazy guy like he's like the resident
crazy guy the guy with the hammer yeah
no way is he homeless he's homeless in
the way that he's he's uh he's an
illegal immigrant from Canada he's a
Canadian illegal immigrant that he
stayed in California because California
has a sanctuary law where they won't
like send him back why not
get him out of here dude let's do some
[ __ ] so then he's kind of like uh this
Hammer guy he's kind of that activist
that you would see at like things like
like they've seen him at rallies for
like nudism or some [ __ ] where like
they're protesting
family while he's butt naked with a
hammer he wasn't his
robbed them he wanted to ask Nancy
questions what are the trade secrets if
she lied he said he was gonna break her
kneecap so that she would show up to the
house uh to the next how how speaker
thing in a wheelchair and they would
send a message that you guys can't lie
or else this will happen that was like
following [ __ ] Wall Street bets and
[ __ ] like he's all like Pelosi capital
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] colluding and [ __ ]
yeah it's it's crazy and uh and the
reason why I I believe it is because I
[ __ ] have seen this [ __ ] happen a lot
in Hollywood Hills where just random
crazy people will break in and just
really [ __ ] yeah so that's kind of a
thing that happens but this is very like
it's very specific in which this guy his
name is the Pape the hammer guy that's
his name yeah he knew where the
residence was yeah he got in there
here's some of the conspiracy theories
oh the glass on the broken door was on
both sides of the door meaning it might
have been a breakout and not a break-in
um people were like hey Paul Pelosi was
in his underwear when they opened the
door and so was the other guy I'll be
sleeping that ended up not being true
that's weird why do people because they
said there was one theory that they're
like um they're just gay lovers like
that was his that was like his side
thing and then like they met at a bar
and then they're hooking up and then
some [ __ ] went South off and then like
Pelosi had to call the cops and then
like a guy like that you think you'd be
able to pick a
hotter dude than this if that's your
side piece
he looks like that one actor what's that
house that's not Pelosi's house is it
that's the garage this guy he plays um
he plays the uh the new Captain America
but the bad guy one uh Black Mirror is
that who it is yeah yeah dude so I was
reading I think it was times or I don't
know whatever but immediately you know
they make it political and they were
saying like q a non Trump supporter they
try to paint him as a far right and
they're like a far-right guy was coming
to kill from Canada right and then
another one was like like how can he be
that and then it showed his house and it
said like black lives matter and it was
a rainbow flag and it was in San
Francisco and then they're like he's a
hardcore liberal like how can he be and
I'm just like wait what the [ __ ] is true
and then now I see that house and I'm
like that's not the same house that I
saw that they were trying to say that's
where he lived yeah why do you think the
media is trying to confuse everybody
like that anything else right away which
side this guy aligns with because
they're like oh they can use it yeah by
the way these are great theories I mean
that's a funny thing because they went
to the neighbor of where this guy was
last living and they were like tell us
about his political alignment like
that's the thing they want to know I'm
just curious like okay she's a pretty
high level like yeah she's her highest
Congress like where was security I
thought they okay yeah that's another
thing I I thought you know and I heard
that they lived in like a gated
community so like where the [ __ ] like I
don't know how the [ __ ] did this guy get
there so easily where was secret service
and then the cops and everything or how
was she conveniently missing she's
always missing because she always leaves
and because you know she's a [ __ ]
house speaker so he's hanging in the
time I was in DC or something but she
was gonna be back in two days basically
what what a lot of things are missing in
terms of information but usually that's
just how these things go with it's
sensitive and there's a like a VIP type
person but they there is one account of
eyewitness and that's the there was a
neighborhood like an ADT guy that was
like driving around uh heat security for
a neighbor not for the Pelosi's and he
was driving around he said he saw the
guy dragging his bag of [ __ ] up the hill
so there's that and also security wise
you would think this house of Pelosi's
would have like round-the-clock
surveillance which they do but they
lacks it they're a little bit more
chilled out when Nancy is not there
not here let's turn off all the [ __ ]
cameras nobody likes Paul dudes they
weren't looking at it so they're not
going to get an active response that's
stupid they'll just be recording things
or maybe for later but you're not going
to get guys actively looking at it and
then going oh we gotta go what if that
was like an insecure that Paul Pelosi
had like come on guys you got to keep
the cameras on all the time like every
time Nancy's gone you guys don't care
about me and then something's gonna
happen he keeps talking about it like
shut the [ __ ] up Paul you're a loser and
then sure enough this happens they set
it up yeah and he thought see I told you
I told you guys something bad was gonna
happen yeah so looking guys what you got
from um just like learning all this [ __ ]
was he's just a crazy dude that just so
happened I think I wouldn't rule out
that he's just a [ __ ] crazy guy and
he's not politically Affiliated or no he
is yeah what do you think president I
think he definitely knows who Nancy
Pelosi is and knows that that's their
house and wanted to do some crazy ass
[ __ ] yeah but I don't think it's like I
don't think they were gay lovers
maybe he's smarter than they're making
him out to be people are saying they're
gay lovers yeah they're saying like
they're saying that Paul Pelosi picked
them up at a gay bar in San Francisco
and they're hooking up and then
something went wrong and then like
that [ __ ] was going down that was one of
the theories another one was like um I
mean both sides like left and right like
they all the extremists always come out
with some funny [ __ ] right they have the
wildest imaginations like on the left
side they're like yeah he's a QA non
hardcore Trump supporter and I'm all
like but dude this guy is like a nudist
and he's gay like that just that doesn't
sound like Trump supporter and like like
conservative to me
[Laughter]
that's pretty interesting that this
story specifically with a high profile
person like Nancy Pelosi has so many
different like talking points so many
different like opposing uh storylines
because you think they'd clear it up
eventually right do you think it's
trying to after the death settled yes
from other things like what really went
down I don't know I mean the thing is
like it does seem like there's there is
a high chance of stuff like this
happening to high profile politicians
yeah for sure these encounters happen a
lot yeah it's just so happens that this
encounter happened at his home and if
encounters like this happen at your home
then it's just a larger slew of rumors
could spring because it's your house but
if you were at a [ __ ] I don't know
like uh like if you're speaking publicly
and someone ran up then it's very easy
everybody sees it such a gay lover like
yeah
he [ __ ] up because he's he should have
went in there and asked for stock advice
he's like yo are you guys investing in
next Mr Paul Pelosi how the [ __ ] did you
crush it harder than a lot of these like
firms in Wall Street you did really well
last year can you teach me like what to
do yeah and it's also in combination
with his with his alcoholic history with
how he got drunk before that they're
like oh he's drunk again and now he's
got his gay lover and he didn't know how
to kick him out and they had a Lover's
spat it's like yeah it's easy to piece
together all these weird things but you
know I like that storyline better it's
more interesting
how insulted would you be if you had a
burglar break into your home and then
they publicized this photo and people
were saying oh that's a Nick's lover a
lot of people think I'm gay already bro
but it's like this dude talk about it
yeah it is like the perfect story though
right hey Nancy's out of town it's time
to go on your gay love spree but why are
they trying to think I want I think it's
it's because of all the security faults
that people are seeing fishiness because
the guy broke glass alarm should go off
yeah I think security should just been
better than that okay then why is it not
okay to have a gay lover see okay that's
number one and number two if if it's not
okay to be a gay lover because of the
political thing why can Mr Paul Pelosi
just they're like hey you're a gay lover
and he could just be like no
yeah where's his State why is that not
okay yeah yeah exactly okay lover no
next question
I'm here to address the rumors that it
was my gay lover that came in and hit me
on the head with a hammer some of you
guys think it's Hammer's always got a
hammer
no it's not I think it does not he's
like wow I agree with that everyone just
has to remember that there is an active
opposite side to this that as soon as
one thing happens they're gonna
capitalize yeah create as much as a q
Anon wouldn't have these these it works
either way but it works easily herself
that was sharing the article that said
that Q Anon and Trump supporter came and
tried to [ __ ] up her husband yeah
because they're both trying to do that
everyone is always trying it's two sides
they're trying to spin it already
Nancy's trying to spin it I don't trust
Nancy I think the the the the sensible
people should rise up against these
[ __ ] crazy asses that are like trying
to spin the narrative and push Americans
against each other and then just be like
yo shut the [ __ ] up like you don't speak
for the rest of us like we're right we
just want a sensible Society we don't
want your crazy asses [ __ ]
controlling the narrative here right
it's like [ __ ] both Progressive hardcore
liberals and [ __ ] hardcore
conservatives that are [ __ ] Ultra
extremists [ __ ] you guys is both do you
think he's gonna get deported now
I don't I don't think so not from Cali
dude get him out of here man get these
Canadians off our soil brother ain't
gonna happen dude for president
I don't like these immigrants in our
country man I feel like political news
are like [ __ ] Tick-Tock dance
challenges you know what I mean it's fun
there's something like gets kind of
viral everyone's like oh we gotta jump
on this oh but we got to put a little
twist on it so it's memorable yeah let's
just change it up a little bit but use
the same facts and it's just like uh if
it goes viral it's worth it that's news
yeah it has nothing to do with facts
it's just like what'd you see what'd you
read I mean it's it's just there's so
much you can do with this because they
looked into the criminal record of of
this guy and also the criminal record of
the woman that he was last living with
and they just found nothing but what
about the criminal record so much about
Pelosi's you know what I mean they're
like oh look at this this guy there's
like molestation there's like child he's
a molester dude a lot of that within
those two people so yeah what's the
story so is he gay or not America
because he just [ __ ] walked over and
ended up in Cali and Cali doesn't do
anything about this
Melissa here bro I don't know
yeah get him out of here dude
Canadian molester I could deal with
overstate his Visa yeah yeah yeah thank
you bro but you can't because California
is a sanctuary state
that's so sweet so we're a we're a
sanctuary state for molesters send them
to ice bro we're a sanctuary state for
everything really yeah then what I don't
know anything about the law man
[Laughter]
foreign